we watched episode 5 together and he was
just staring at it and he's like this is
tough and he said there's power and
weakness but like bro I was like dying
my security and stuff were coming into
the room at night to check my pulse like
people don't know how serious it got
like it was legit crazy scary hi Michael
D Ratner director of Justin Bieber
seasons the documentary that is really
taking not only the internet but truly
the world by storm I want to start at
the beginning tell me how did you and
Justin Bieber get linked up I was
working on a another music anthology
series with Scooter Braun and SB
projects and scooter said to me you got
to check out this footage we're talking
about doing a documentary and Joe
termini who is a co-director on a bunch
of the episodes was filming Justin just
behind the scenes everywhere is going
during like the very nascent stages of
his album making and I saw this and I
was like you need to get me in a room
with him like I just I just want to see
what he wants to do with this I think it
could be really special and we sat there
and we talked about what the project
could become and we were aligned because
he wanted to go and tell the real story
as well which is what I obviously wanted
to do and you know from there Joe myself
Justin we put together something I'm
quite proud of what was your like plan
or strategy going into it it was to make
a Doc series it was to film Verte style
and then mix in like the Talking Heads
in DC and get his close collaborators
got poohbear and Josh Goodwin and Haley
and obviously Justin himself and scooter
and Allison Ryan good to get all of
those voices to go and tell this story
accurately I always like to think about
the audience we're making it for you
know we're on YouTube where he was born
and coming back home to YouTube and then
having that be a free global platform
where everybody could see this thing and
if you want to see it early for super
fan go get YouTube premium right like I
think all of those things made it
special and that's what we set out to do
what was your vision going into this I
know as a filmmaker you probably have
specific things that you're like I'm not
doing this unless I can do it this way
what were those things for you to tell
Justin Bieber the the human being story
you know not the global superstar not
the glossy version those are
intrinsically tied but it was
how do you go and tell a human interest
story I mean it's like a human story and
he's the first I mean we talked about
this in the dock
he is the first global superstar
megastar of the social media tonight and
that has ramifications that effects and
consequences I think he's doing a pretty
good job
no one's ever grown up in history
humanity like Justin Bieber no one's
ever been that famous worldwide in an
era of social media and everybody's had
to watch him go through every single
phase the light of life why now why do
this documentary now I think that and I
with fear of sounding cheesy or too on
the nose it's a season it's not his
whole life and I think that capturing
this moment in time and being able to
reflect on some of the stuff that's been
reported or there was sort of ambiguity
about is important as he goes and
reintroduces himself to the world there
was a time when I was sipping I was
popping pills I was doing Molly anything
there's a lot of heavy topics in this
docu-series what shock to you the most
did you know that he would be opening up
about substance abuse about Lyme disease
health issues we spare no piece of
information that there's nothing
off-limits there's no restriction list
and he really talks about everything and
it's not just one issue I mean he talks
about his Lyme disease and the drug use
and obviously mono and and there's sort
of a and and a lot of these different
heavy subject matters because I think
that for him it was cathartic in some
ways to go and say here's my story
here's some of the things that I've been
going through and whether you're a
global superstar whether you're me you
anybody you know we all have issues that
we deal with so I think by being brave
and going out there and saying I'm gonna
talk about some of the struggles I had
he's actually gonna help quite a few
people I think it's very relatable
because if you haven't gone through it
yourself you know someone who's gone
through it and therefore you have like
those feelings but you mentioned there
was no restriction list when you guys
met up and said let's do this he didn't
say this and this and this those are no
goes no not one thing and I kept waiting
for it to be oh yeah yeah no he really
was an open book and I think that that
says a lot about him well I'll tell you
one line that he said to me that has
stuck with me forever well as we watched
episode 5 together
he was just staring at it and he's like
this is tough and he said there's power
and weakness and I thought when he said
that you know he said the very reasons
why it's sometimes uncomfortable for me
to watch that as the reasons I wanted
out there
so he's watching these episodes back
with you I've watched the episodes with
it man wow that must be a very
fascinating experience are you watching
him like what was the expression on his
face watching all that jarring footage
back yeah I think it's tough to watch
yourself on screen I think it's tough to
also watch something that you've made
with this person but no it's important
because I think that we wanted to go and
make it as strong as it could be so we'd
watch it together and we'd have deep
conversations about why things were a
certain way but it was never a place of
subjectivity or trying to make Justin
Bieber commercial he was never trying to
just use this as a vehicle to push album
sales it's really how do I tell my story
are there any tears in those viewing
sessions yeah yeah I mean what do you
think makes him emotional I think that
he's he's got a great heart so as he
reflects on different relationships he
has and people that have stuck with him
and I think he does get emotional you
know he certainly broke down which was I
think reported that his listening party
because he was thanking a lot of people
in the audience for their involvement
helping him get to this point I think he
takes great pride and where he's at
today I was waking up in the morning the
first thing I was doing is popping pills
and smoking a blunt and starting my day
you know so it just got scary I want to
know as you're doing all these
interviews and people are making
confessions and they're describing in
detail what he went through what made
your jaw drop on the floor maybe some of
the candid open conversation about prior
drug use but nothing made my charge I
mean we talked about it that's such a
life ahead of filming you knew that you
guys were gonna tackle all of all of
this yeah I mean in that first meeting
we really we got on the same page and I
think that's what made our relationship
work so well nothing really made my jaw
drop because I I knew we were going
there I think I was more thrilled that
it ultimately went that way you know it
sounds like you had a dream subject to
work with yeah he was great I am here in
the doctor's office and what we are
about to do is the nurse is gonna put in
a
an IV and it's called nad it's gonna
flush out some of the toxins you guys
take the cameras inside a doctor's
office one of the most intimate things
you can do on camera that is such a
vulnerable state how emotional was it
watching Justin talk about this
procedure that he's having and and be so
open about that experience he never
wavered from what he said you do I will
provide the access you tell the story he
basically stays consistent throughout as
far as his willingness and his behavior
with cameras around we were able to go
and sometimes we'd be very light lift
we're you know just get one camera cuz
for me you'll notice in the documentary
it wasn't about always having the
glossiest nicest shots there's something
what made it feel yeah you should walk
away from some of this up saying I
shouldn't have just seen that I
shouldn't be here basically the
infections have played a big part of my
acne feels good now to know why I feel
so crappy all the time is there anything
in the documentary that we are not going
to see things you filmed that Justin
said let's pull back I don't want that
to make it to air there's there's a
tremendous amount of footage that people
will not see because we shot and we shot
and we shot but nothing for that reason
there's nothing that was cut from the
edit because he said this goes too far
it was really like let's get it all in
there when you're Justin Bieber it's
hard to respond to each you know false
report or fake headline I think here he
used this as an opportunity to say what
really do I want to speak about not
necessarily as a response to that but to
set the record straight about his life
and what was going on
so you know whereas I think many people
might shy away from that stuff instead
we really gravitated towards it so that
we can go and address it and then move
on we're there any moments where you
needed to take five where things got a
little too emotional the tears were
coming it was too hard to talk about and
you need it to be like let's let's turn
the cameras down for a second no there
was never any moment where we had to
turn the cameras down there's moments
where you know right after we do this
heavy hour-and-a-half interview a lot of
which is in episode 5 he leaned off and
he was just like it feels so good to
share this stuff he says I don't think I
was mature enough to do this prior and
and that wasn't spoke that wasn't for
the camera but it did end up in the cut
to see the authentic nature of Haley and
Justin's relationship and
it does not change when those cameras go
away and I think that Justin is who he
is as well and and and really what you
see is what you get my wife she's in the
back she makes everything better you
make everything better baby I want to
move into Justin and Haley because it's
such an integral part yeah not only this
documentary but truly like it to me as a
viewer it seems like she saved his life
like she seems like such an important
part of his mental his physical his his
everything and I want to know as having
like a front-row seat to their marriage
their relationship
what's the dynamic and what do you take
away from their relationship I think
that they're meant to be I mean they've
got a fantastic relationship I think
that she's obviously a tremendous wife
and they're working on being a really
you know strong unit where they're just
working on making their marriage work
and living a as a stable of a life as
you can well being you know well your
life is very not normal yeah did it
surprise you to see how much of a
caretaker Haley is I mean I'm watching
her zipping him into this hyperbaric
chamber she's monitoring what time he
should be taking medication did that
take you by surprise no I think
specifically obviously the documentary
on Justin in the album so you see her
doing those things for him it goes both
ways and I think that she's a great wife
you know she's there to make sure that
he's got what he needs and he's taken
care of and it goes both ways that
really that that's a phenomenal two-way
relationship he talks in the documentary
about how he always wanted to be a
husband and he really wants to be a
father you think that's in the cards
they're not gonna happen soon so yeah
yeah I have no insider information I I
think so yeah knowing what you know of
him what kind of father do you think he
will be I think he's gonna be a great
dad he's fantastic with kids and I have
this thickest chick in the game she's so
awesome he still makes me a little
nervous sometimes like I blush and I get
a little bit like cheesy this wedding is
almost like it's the reward it's the
cherry on top what's it like for you to
watch a guy who's gone through so many
ups and downs and to finally make it to
that incredible sweet moment I think
there's a few there's there's cherries
on cherries yeah you know like it's the
wedding episode is obviously great and
it feels like a win if you invest in
this documentary you get to that point
and you feel pride and certainly if
you're rooting for him as our
protagonist and it feels pure and real
what are people gonna see in that
wedding episode everything that's it
yeah it's you see cows walking down the
aisle all of that yeah moments before
Haley obviously getting ready and Justin
with his friends and family getting
ready I mean and it's it's really cool
it's a special episode because I think
that there was so much interest in that
and they allowed us to really capture it
and share it with the world
[Music]